les gilet jaune lui avait même donné un
surnom la borne jaune et depuis ce matin
fini les permanences de nuit comme de
jour
et si les gilet jaune sont devenus
invisibles à besançon ils restent
déterminés à jouer samedi
l'acte 5 de leur mouvement à une petite
heure de route de là dans le jura c'est
une tout autre stratégie qui
s'installent autour de dole durée sans
gêner seuls les camions sont bloqués
pendant un petit moment ils nous
rejoignent pas donc sans eux on s'en
fout on peut rester encore là longtemps
quoi donc là ce qu'on veut c'est
vraiment bloqué les camions pour pour
paralyser un petit peu le pays quoi pour
durcir un petit peu notre mouvement
on laisse partir tout doucement
comme ça entre -2 et -3 négocier pour
durer partager aussi mais gilet jaune du
jura ont reversé 10000 euros pour le
téléthon et eux reçoivent du
ravitaillement
cette solidarité a ses propres
frontières la majorité de ces gels et je
n'entende pas l'appel à la trêve et à la
responsabilité après l' attaque
terroriste de strasbourg bat greek ce
serait très important on peut pas
arrêter la manifestation peut pas
arrêter d'amuser ses stations c'est un
autre monde sait c'est une autre chose
là deux choses bien différentes il ya
les victimes du terrorisme
et puis les manifestations des gilets
jaunes c'est pas toi malga mais quoi
autre rond-point dolois même
détermination eux ce qu'ils ont en tête
c'est d'obtenir beaucoup plus que les
annonces du président de la république
et puis il ya ceux encore minoritaires
qui commence à douter
déjà dans la haute saône le préfère peut
les arrêter dans le doubs également le
jura on encore tolérés mais jusqu'à
quand on est dans une impasse avec
l'attentât d'istanbul et beaucoup de
choses
présent dès le 17 novembre
ce jeune homme marc chaque jour sur son
gilet comme un pas vers une libération
et rien pas même à l'attentât ne semble
éloigné de son rêve